I went in there with just wanting a nose
job and my lips tongue and he made me
feel like my entire face was messed up I
left in tears because I thought I am so
hideous my name is Jenna I do anti-aging
research and consulting my name is
Tanisha aka vitiligo queen I do a lot of
advocacy for vitiligo awareness hi I'm
Rena and I'm an actress my name is Carly
I'm a healthy lifestyle coach
my name is Sagar Patel and I'm a facial
plastic surgeon in Beverly Hills my name
is Nicola Lowry I am a physician
assistant practicing aesthetic medicine
I've been practicing for 14 years and
I'm a national trainer for Allergan the
makers of Botox and fillers my natural
beauty folks on the left and my cosmetic
surgery group on the right
the cosmetic-surgery industry exploits
people's insecurities I don't think the
industry as a whole does its money right
so I think there are there's motivation
behind women not feeling good about
themselves and I do think there are
certain companies and individuals who
would exploit that in order to make it
more lucrative for them it just makes
sense that's how businesses work some
places where they tell you like bring
out those insecurities because I want
them to buy these products I mean like
at a training they tell you right and
I'm not gonna do that to someone it's
like oh well you have this dissing this
wrong maybe you want to fix it I'm not
gonna do that to somebody and create an
insecurity in them that maybe they knew
they had and not playing on it or maybe
they didn't know but now they do
definitely I was only 18 when I called
for my console I said I would like to
have a console for a rhinoplasty and lip
injections and he gave me that I needed
cheek implants I needed to have my brow
line shaved down because changing my
nose would change the entire shape of my
face and I felt very much so like he
just saw me as money there's good
doctors and bad doctors and in the end
the important thing to realize is that
doctors are trying to do good for other
people there's exceptions but it's a
professional society where our goal is
to help other people and you know
initially going in to the cosmetic world
especially it's a multi-billion dollar
industry and as a doctor you're always
taught a couple of laurels from
benevolence to do no harm the insecurity
is inherent in all of us
some of us have more some of us have
less but it was already there and you
know does the cosmetic industry
capitalize on our insecurities sure I
think that there is a piece of that but
as all industries they're just trying to
market to the people that
are going to utilize their product I
wish I could change something about my
appearance yeah I feel like just because
I want to change something about myself
doesn't necessarily mean that I don't
accept myself those are the thoughts
that prompt me to work on acceptance of
myself something that I come across a
lot in my practice is not so much that
someone wants to change the way that
they look but they want to preserve it
there's a lot of issues especially with
women with the aging process it's not so
much that they want to be somebody else
so they want to look like somebody else
but they want to stay looking like them
I fully intend to do a facelift when the
time is right and not because I want to
look different but because I want to
continue to look as young as I feel yeah
I think for me major decision for me to
get cosmetic surgery was that I was in
my early 20s and I had had a massive
weight loss I lost the weight I lost 175
pounds and my skin looked like a nine
year old so for me I consider more like
reconstructive and kind of getting back
to what I was supposed to be before I
did you know some damage to myself for
me I spent my entire childhood into my
early adult life wishing I looked
different I promised myself that I would
never ever tell myself I wish I had this
I wish I looked like this because I
found that triggered things for me that
brought back places that I used to be
with my eating disorder I think that's
great and I hope you don't take offense
to this but you're gorgeous thank you
and I feel like if I was if I was
naturally that like beautiful it
wouldn't be that hard to like be like oh
my god my face is gorgeous you know I'm
gonna accept myself there are people who
have facial deformities and embody
deformities like we're kind of what I
consider what I went through
it's a little harder yeah oh definitely
yes might have a pretty face but I was
always the largest of all of my friends
the largest of my family five years of
my life I spent constantly constantly
waking up in the morning and picking
apart every single part of my body I
can't continue this constant terrible
habit of bulimia or I'm going to die so
it was just I was horribly bulimic for a
year now like it was awful yeah cosmetic
surgery can empower you
I do wish that every woman could wake up
and look in the mirror and be like I am
so beautiful just the way I am but I
also think that if you can do something
to give yourself that feeling then
that's really great and that is a
beautiful thing so one of the questions
we actually asked on our questionnaires
what are your motivations for surgery
and someone who says I can't get a
boyfriend you know I'm getting bad
grades because I have this particular
look they're a bad candidate for surgery
and you know that's part of medical
school training that's part of becoming
a surgeon is understanding what these
triggers are what are the signs that
tell you as a surgeon this is not going
to be someone who's going to be happy
afterwards whether or not you are
inherently truly happy or not I think
that's hugely important but what if
you're a happy person but you hate your
nose or what if you're a very happy
person
and you were born with a cleft palate
and you want to be able to project your
image to the world that's congruent with
how you feel on the inside and maybe
you're experiencing negativity because
of the way you were born naturally every
day I experience stories of empowerment
with patients but for me a particular
one comes essentially from someone who
was so unempowered by her experiences
this girl she was 23 at the time was
beat by her father when she was younger
and
significant trauma to her nose and
helping her and fixing her nose and the
gratitude she showed and realizing that
you didn't help her for that day you
didn't help her for that week for the
rest of her life she can start moving on
and that empowerment is one of the
perfect example of what cosmetic surgery
and that truly was that it was just a
cosmetic surgery it was not so she could
breathe it wasn't so she could move
around better it was to make her look a
certain way so she doesn't have to
remember that experience there is too
much pressure on women to look a certain
way
we live in a instant life now with you
know we have dating apps or you can
swipe hundreds of people a day and you
know you can go online and post a good
selfie of yourself and get you know
hundreds of likes and you feel like
there's so much pressure to look and be
a certain way like you can never fall if
you just kind of look at the way that
things are changing around pregnancy a
lot of women now want to go and have a
baby with a beat face like everything is
perfect it's about the perfect picture I
have to have my makeup in my brows now I
understand some things you just want to
be perfect
I get it I want to I want to be able to
just embrace the moments with my child
and not worry about all this makeup I
have one right now I think we've been
kind of comparing you know say the 25
year old to the 25 year old but then
let's think about the women that are
middle-aged and are having to keep up
with the younger girls to try and still
feel attractive and relevant and I do
see that a lot even with my clientele I
have women that are married to very
wealthy men and that their greatest fear
is that they will end up becoming the
second wife because the new-and-improved
wife is on her way in and she's on her
way out so this pressure to maintain
youth and beauty and relevance is so
huge for not really realizing that it's
that man there's a jerk it's not us it's
really the person that you're with and
so I think that always having to keep up
with the Joneses and I always wanted to
just like I have to look this way
because this person has to love me and
if this person doesn't love me
I might have to I have to make myself be
who he loves to take it it's a lot of
pressure I am beautiful
okay so I'm gonna go first because I
woke up this morning and I really loved
myself
with me having vitiligo it took a long
time when I first was diagnosed at five
no one knew what it was
everyone thought Michael Jackson made it
up like it's a real thing no one knew
that it was real so a lot of people's
first time encountering what it actually
looked like a person was me I took a
long time for me to get to this point to
where I'm just like oh I love Who I am
I'm super beautiful for things that I do
not particularly how I look I'm you know
how cute but I feel so beautiful for the
way that I make other people feel and
just how I love myself one of the the
things that happened with me gaining the
weight really fast and then losing it
really fast asite have a lot of stretch
marks I have a friend who's really into
body positivity and she's a photographer
and she took pictures of these ugly
parts of me and she's just like wow that
is so beautiful and like I could see
through her eyes like I'm starting to
see myself in that way even those things
that will never get fixed there is no
way to fix them there is no way to
replace my skin with other skin it's
different but it's beautiful you know
there's one message that I want to get
out to men today a simple thing like
someone telling you you look beautiful
without being creepy of course but
someone just telling you you look
beautiful all of you guys look beautiful
that makes a big difference to everyone
tell people who you make yourself
because men are beautiful too correct I
thank you guys for this experience you
guys are amazing
[Music]
hi guys my name is Aaron and I'm from
Jubilee media I really hope you enjoyed
this video and took something away from
both sides we really try to encourage
people to listen to others because we
believe that's the first step to change
and so check out our other work tell us
what you think below and we hope you
will watch another video of our soon
[Music]